les journalistes attachés de presse du
monde entier réunis pour préparer les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 un briefing mondial
était organisé du 4 au 7 septembre avec
les organisateurs au programme notamment
la visite des sites dans les Yvelines
ils ont pu découvrir le vélo de national
de 50 ans en Yvelines le Stadium de BMX
et le château de Versailles des
enceintes sportives qui ont impressionné
les médias
[Musique]
ils ont une grande expérience pour
organiser des événements internationaux
bien sûr ce n'est pas la première fois
que Paris va organiser les Jeux
Olympiques
sera une très bonne expérience de
concours et ici
et de voir toutes sortes de matchs ici
pendant la semaine les 400 journalistes
et attachés de presse présents en plus
récolter des informations sur les
différents sites sur les accréditations
sur les transports ou la sécurité ils
ont pu poser des questions à
l'organisation
le briefing Media est très important
pour moi parce qu'il y aura beaucoup de
journalistes et de photographes qui vont
venir l'année prochaine à Paris c'est
pourquoi le briefing est très important
avec beaucoup de nouvelles informations
qui nous arrivent après le château de
Versailles il a tourné c'est terminé par
la visite des sites olympiques parisiens
le briefing s'est ensuite clôturé par un
discours de la ministre des Sports
Amélie odé à Castéra les médias se
retrouveront désormais l'année prochaine
pour les JO il devrait être plus de 4000
journalistes et 1500 photographes
acritée
[Musique]